maxime collier worked as a substitute
school teacher in the paris region for
seven years he had to move schools often
and was always on short contracts he was
passionate about the profession but gave
it up because he was frustrated with the
system and the instability
you were doing the same job as a staff
teacher your colleagues treat you the
same and i had regular inspections like
everyone that went well so the job is
great but what's difficult is that after
a while it gets tiring because you are
changing schools all the time and there
comes a point where you need something
reliable
this year 4 000 staff teaching jobs in
france are unfilled so the french
government's calling on substitute
teachers to help alleviate the shortage
some have no classroom experience so
they're given a four day crash course
before being thrown into the deep end
said farmer
no this training gives us a lot of
pointers tools and resources but then
it's clear we will have to learn on the
job
trade unions say that instead of relying
on substitute teachers the government
should take a closer look at why there
aren't enough staff teachers in the
first place they say the problem is that
the profession is underpaid and
undervalued
as children return to school in france
after the summer break some say the
education system is in crisis
what we want today is to be able to work
in good conditions to be better paid and
have smaller classes
france's education minister papangay
says he understands teachers
frustrations he says salaries will be
reviewed before the end of the year but
unions say they're fed up of promises
they've called for a strike at the end
of the month because they say the
government is out of tune with their
concerns
natasha butler al jazeera paris